flucht kasse
nein alter machen dieses game
das ist einmal vergebens als einfach
viel kleiner ist man kann einfach nur
irgendwo also ich was ich gerade mache
ist chillen und grillen zwei besten
alter wisst ihr was was ich mache jetzt
alles ums essen alter ich glaube darauf
war keiner gekommen war ich alle ich bin
ja nicht der einzige der rom läuft also
der einzige in dem man so sieht er wieso
ich laufe auch die gastro ist undercover
markieren flüchten probiere träumen zu
killen bin ich ja doch warum wir haben
sie etwa das gleiche ziel bist du weißt
nicht was ich alles im inventar haare
was nicht zum inventar
doch alter meister jetzt habe ich fast
vergessen was ich machen wollte
nein ich habe es nicht ganz vergessen zu
meinem glück gibt's keine investor
ich wäre richtig dreist gewesen ich
hätte mir die karte gemacht was braucht
man für das ist ein bisschen gold also
da kannst du ja ja ja das war meine idee
aber dann fiel mir ein scheiß sie vorher
kompass redstone die elversberger selig
mit mir doch ein kompass und karte
machen etwas bringt euch ein körpers
kein batstone doch mal was bringt euch
eine karte 29 redstone einmal zwingend
einen von euch teleportieren weil immer
hinter kiel alles ein bisschen sacken ab
ich war nur noch reisen
ich war nur noch eine waffe habe hier
ganz in diesem sinn diesen ganzen
höhere aufnahmestopp lebt jetzt hier das
duell der giganten das duell der
giganten acht teams stand da ich habe
mich kannst du die hinter lee portiert
gerade gerade wollte wollte er mal hier
zu gucken wollte gerade irgendwann kurz
gucken ob ich noch reisen haben oder
kräftiger in die pfütze junge nicht in
mich rein auch an he alter heute ist
sein wird lappen ja locken
mister outback wäre da war das war das
an die das bin ich erst weiter auf noch
bei uns ist ja egal was stimmt aber der
ist liebe crafter kann es erkennt mich
machen
also liebe zuschauer jetzt grad mal kurz
bei mir wenn ihr das sitzen nicht aus
meiner perspektive sehen wollt dann
klickt in die beschreibung dort findet
ihr links und so weiter weil bei mir ist
glaube ich ein bisschen langweilt alter
als er das ging gerade ab hier mit
angeht musste grenze xp mode ist hatte
ich auch aber nicht so viel hat ein und
der pfeil der feier der bogen kam aus
der mitte der war in der chest in der
ganzen mitte wurde für die
diamantenabbau musstest großen matches
zwischen den diamanten nein nein du mich
war da ich war als allererster ja
scheinbar nicht abgebaut ich hatte keine
alten spielzeug und leiste das genau das
musste ich mich noch besorgen bevor ich
da hingehen und fertig den bogen hat
scheiße
wer hat der hat mich gerade echt
gerettet gerettet der richtigen damit
den diamant schwer traf er beim du legst
irgendwie so bald von den bogen
angeschlossen wird das total komisch
gehe ja du bist du zum glück nur einen
ratschlag geben was denn eine party mit
tnt
ich hab realen du hast 10 tnt oder so
vielleicht dann insgesamt
ich bin zu blöd mein eigenheim zu
finanzieren als komplette tnt hochgejagt
damit könnte ich wohl aber von mai an
die sag mir wie man sagt man wie man
sich so ein scheiß bogen macht sagt
einfach nur wie man sich einen scheiß
bogen
du hast so drei eltern mit oben in der
mitte rechts der mitte ganz rechts unten
in der mitte und dann kommt das sind
ganz links in ein quasi so ein dreieck
an die mal ganz kurz steht der typ hat
vor die vor mir ja ich sehe ihn nicht xx
ja das bak das hatten wir letztens schon
mal dass das so war
also brauche ich fix und an denen kann
ich den kampf noch gar nicht sehen auch
dass rollt an die könnte es noch mal
locken das könnte vielleicht
funktioniert dann ist das game mit der
aufnahme er dann sagt jetzt machen soll
wie hoch ist 1 oben erzählt unsere apps
ihre das wäre nicht das problem recht
nah dran
ach so dann kann ich jetzt als ablenkung
1003 mittendrin dabei helfen in der
mittleren reihe ganz rechts einstiegs ja
meine sticks und dann und linke seite
komplett an sich sehe euch wer macht
sich denn so einen bogen und kilian sich
auch in der randvoll kilian weg und das
wird spannend
die langläufer die gelernt überhaupt ich
sehe mich als er ach us open wieder eine
rüstung erreicht war eine partie die man
juristen urteilen bist du hast dich als
eisen gehabt ich hatte reisen
die kann man sich keine witze machen ist
doch das was um sich macht nach dem
schwert einfach cool sein wollte es ist
bettel nicht minecraft so gut da wir
noch gesagt ich dachte irgendwie bei
minecraft alters kilian und wurst system
du bist so ein lappen ohne mit kalter
ventil einmal rüber kommt bist du so tot
ich habe
ein netzwerk facebook das neuenburg dort
kann man zum glück wieder aufnehmen
ich hab so viele pfeile von mir gekriegt
haben ja ich habe glücklicherweise sogar
noch 16 gefunden in der kiste doch 43
habe ich also 33 ich bin wieder bei
kräften
oder wer auch immer sich dann in gent
mit table eingestellt hat das bin ich
das sind wir nicht ich bin weiterhin
behalten und nur am rand des canyon am
weitere alter jetzt wird jetzt kommt der
britische kämpfe er hat sie ihre
netzwerke mit so verpacken oder sowas
komplette palette flucht hier raus und
eimer oder la vida jedoch einfach auf
der organe
hast du hast du noch drei eisen ich hab
mich einfach nur da hoch ich hab dich
aber ich hab keinen bock dass er mich
dann hast du denn noch nein denn noch
alles wirklich alles was man so nicht
braucht schon vorerst
man sieht also keine drei eisen auf den
keks gehen
eiskalte springt im segment unser klima
laut dem lauf hinter mir ich höre viele
saurier netzwerk hin
ich brauchte einfach nur zu meinem
netzwerk fairplay hat
seit ich dich jetzt noch retten können
aber wo ist denn hier ein spiel gewonnen
und damit das chianti
ich bin da ja vielleicht können wir ja
noch mal dritter der dritte teil unter
der zweite teil keine ahnung ja da wird
noch mal so was in die richtung kommen
wird ich einfach mal sagen jedenfalls
sehr spaßig mit euch also wäre es fairer
kampf fand ich ja die map ansicht war
ganz gut aber ich war schlecht
ich bin zu viel weg gelaufen glaube ich
ja also wir hoffen es hat euch gefallen
und bot uns noch sagen könnt euch ein
abo oder lasst es bleiben bis zum
nächsten mal